you
hello hello mayor speak to Robert
Shiller please hello my name is Adam
Smith I'm calling from the note from
nobelprize.org the official website of
the Nobel Prize in Stockholm we have a
tradition of recording very short
interviews with new laureates could we
just speak for a few minutes yeah thank
you very much indeed well first of all
many congratulations on the prize thank
you
how did you hear the news I was getting
ready to leave on a trip to Phoenix
Arizona and what was your first reaction
do you think this do you think the trip
to Phoenix is going to go ahead
well it's postponed there may be careful
how do you think the day is going to pan
out have you imagined yourself in this
position before have you imagined how
you might react to it if the news came
because friends of mine repeatedly tell
me they think that they expect me to win
it but I've always reflected that there
are so many worthy people who was the
first person you told after you after
the household I woke my wife up I just
wanted to ask you how just one question
because this is going to expose your
field of research to a very wide
audience who weren't previously been
aware of it it's all to do with the
predictability of asset pricing how good
a handle do you think we have on that do
you think it's very much a work in
progress or have we got things pretty
well worked out
yeah well I could really say that it's
it we've learned a lot about asset
pricing but there's a basic human
element in it that is irreducible so
predicting what assets prices will do is
partly similar to trying to predict what
one person will do and so it should
there ever be a science in predicting
what you will be doing no because
there's an irreducible human element and
that's part of the reason why the the
field of Finance will never completely
understand a bit frightning movement
that was a lovely very understandable
comment thank you very much indeed
ok so I look forward to talking again at
length later in the autumn but for now
let me wish you a wonderful day and
congratulations alright thank you